START THE APRIL TWENTY NINTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE HEARING --
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO
WE'RE GONNA START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND THEN -- TAKE VOTES
WHEN WE HAVE MEMBERS.
ARE WE DO HAVE OUR FIRST AUTHOR
HERE KASHER TASHA BURNER ****
BATH -- IS UNDER HER ABOUT YOU
WANT TO COME UP AND PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES --
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO THINK OF THE CHAIR AND HER
STAFF. FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
SPELL AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE MOMENTS WE'VE DISCUSSED AND
AGREED UPON.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WAS TO
SUPPORT OUR STATE SMALL BECAUSE
THE CITIES THAT ARE WRESTLING
WITH BEST PRACTICES FOR ONLINE
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
COMPANIES.
THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE ACCEPTED OR
TO CLARIFY THAT THE BILL ONLY
APPLIES O RESIDENTIAL AREAS SO
NO AREAS ZONED FOR RESIDENTIAL
TOURISM WILL BE SUBJECT TO THIS
REQUIREMENT WHICH I THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO SOME OF OUR
LOCAL CITIES.
ELIMINATES REFERENCES TO THE
COAST -- ACCOMMODATIONS PROGRAM
AS SHORT TERM RENTALS DO NOT
FALL UNDER THAT PROGRAMS PURVIEW.
AND IT CREATES A REVIEW
MECHANISM BY THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
IN THE MIDST OF CALIFORNIA STATE
WHAT HOUSING CRISIS THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE IS OF PARTICULAR
PARTICULARLY ACUTE IN THE
COASTAL ZONE.
CITIES FACED COMPOUNDED BARRIERS
TO REGULATING SHORT TERM RENTALS
WHEN SEEKING TO MINIMIZE OUR VAN
THE NUMBER OF THESE RENTALS AND
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE RECENT SPIKE OF SHORT TERM
RENTALS OF RESIDENTIAL UNITS
REDUCES THE AVAIL THE
AVAILABILITY.
OF ALREADY SCARCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND MANY COSTA
COMMITTEES.
ANY UNIT REMOVE FROM OURS OWNS
HOUSING STOCK IS DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO REPLACE.
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA NATIONWIDE
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING TO STRIKE A
BALANCE TO REGULATE ONLINE
VACATION RENTALS. FOR ALMOST A
DECADE SHORT TERM PLATFORMS AND
THEIR OWN TELLING HAVE BEEN.
A RESOURCE FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS
AN EXTRA SOURCE OF INCOME FOR
FAMILIES IN NEED OF AN ECONOMIC
BOOST.
HOWEVER THERE IS A SHIFT IN THE
INDUSTRY THAT'S PROVING
DETRIMENTAL TO SMALL RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES WERE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS ALREADY CHALLENGING
DEFINE WE SEE THIS EVERY DAY AND
MY COMMUNITIES AND NORTH COUNTY
SAN DIEGO. FOR A BUT ALSO FROM
I'D BE ALL THE WAY UP TO
CARLSBAD.
AND I THINK A OF VERY PERTINENT
EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THAT AND MARKET IN COASTAL
CITIES.
IS AN IMPAIR IMPERIAL BEACH THEY
PUT IN A HOT TWO HUNDRED UNIT --
PROJECT TO ADD MORE HOUSING
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT --
TOOK A LOT OF POLITICAL WELL AS
IT ALWAYS DOES AND CLOSE THE
CITY SO IT'S A BILL MORE HOUSING
THEY DID IT.
AND TWENTY FIVE YOUR TWENTY FIVE
OF THOSE UNITS ARE ALREADY FULL
TIME SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
IT'S AN EIGHTH OF THE UNIT'S.
INTENDED FOR FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT WILL NOT BE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NOW -- AND SO
IN THE DECADE SINCE THE
POPULARIZATION OF THE ONLINE
HOME SHARING INDUSTRY SAN
DIEGO'S INVENTORY OF SHORT TERM
RENTALS HAS GROWN TO MORE THAN.
ELEVEN THOUSAND THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH ARE ENTIRE HOMES THAT ARE
BEING WRENCHED OUT FOR SHORT
TERM STAYS.
SHORT TERM RENTALS OF CREATING
NEXUS BETWEEN TOURISM HOUSING
THAT IN AREAS OUR EXPERIENCE
THEM UP EXPERIENCING THE MOST
PROFOUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CHALLENGES HURTS RENTERS WE KNOW
WHEN YOU REMOVE HOUSING FROM THE
HOUSING STOCK.
IT INCREASES RENTAL PRICES AND
YOU'RE SEEING PEOPLE NOT BEING
ABLE TO FIND A PLACE TO RENT IN
OUR COASTAL ZONE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
UCLA ANDERSON SCHOOL OF BUSINESS
CONSIDERS LA'S HIGH COST OF
HOUSING A SIGNIFICANT DRAG ON
JOB CREATION.
THE NEARLY TEN THOUSAND UNITS
TAKEN OFF THE RENTAL MARKET BY
SHORT TERM RENTAL PROPERTY
PLATFORMS IS EQUIVALENT TO SEVEN
YEARS OF A HORDE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT I I
WANT TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU IS
IS TO SAY.
THIS IS A SEVERE PROBLEM AND IF
WE DON'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
WE ARE IN YOU KNOW WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO BUILD OURSELVES OUT OF
THIS CRISIS BUT WE CERTAINLY
WON'T BUILD OURSELVES OUT OF THE
CRISIS WHEN WERE BLEEDING AWAY
UNITS TO SHOW THE SHORT TERM
FATE.
PERMANENT SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS.
IN VENICE AS MANY AS 12% OF ALL
HOUSING UNITS HAVE BECOME AIRBNB
UNITS WITHOUT PUBLIC APPROVAL ON
THAT EQUATES.
TO THREE HUNDRED SIXTY SAU SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTAL UNITS PER
SQUARE MILE.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE COMBATS
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
SHORT TERM RENTAL PLATFORMS AND
WE GIVE CALIFORNIA SMALL BECAUSE
THE CITY'S.
COMMONSENSE TOOLS TO HELP INSURE
ONLINE MENTAL PLATFORMS ARE
OPERATING THE WAY THEY WERE
INTENDED THAT MEANS FOR HOME
SHARING.
WHILE PRESERVING ACCESS TO THE
COAST FOR SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS FOR PRIMARY RESIDENCE AS
SPECIFIED SO THE BILL.
CLEARLY IF THE PRIMARY RESIDENCE
IS ON SITE THEY DO NOT FALL
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THIS BILL.
IF THE PRIMARY RESIDENCE IS NOT
ON SITE THEY CAN.
RENT OVER ONE OF THE ARE THE
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
PLATFORM CAN RENT THAT UNIT FOR
UP TO THIRTY DAYS PER PLATFORM
SO IT'S A TOTAL OF ABOUT NINETY
DAYS PER YEAR -- AND THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO IMPORTANTLY REQUIRE
THE HOUSING PLATFORM FACILITATOR
OF THE SHORT TERM RENTAL TO
COLLECT THE SAME. TO YOUR TO TAX
THAT HOTELS ARE REQUIRED TO
COLLECT TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE FAIRLY
COMPENSATED. FOR THE INCREASE
PUBLIC SERVICE COSTS AND FOR A
CORD BY SERVING TAURUS.
OUR STATE HOUSING GOALS TO
PROVIDE THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
ADDITIONAL HOUSING IN ON THE
MARKET BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE HOWEVER
HOUSING IS THE RENT ON A SHIP
PERMANENT SHORT TERM BASIS.
LESS THAN THIRTY DAYS A YEAR OUR
THIRTY LEARN THIRTY DAYS AT A
TIME FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR DEAR.
BY DEFINITION REMOVES HOUSING
FROM OUR HOUSING HOUSING STOCK
OFTEN PERMANENTLY WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS WE DO NOT HAVE A
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL PRICE
CRISIS IN THE STATE.
SO I ALTHOUGH THIS LEGISLATION
TO PROVIDE TOOLS FOR SMALL
COASTAL CITIES EMPOWER SHORT
TERM RENTAL PLATFORMS TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AS THEY
INTENDED TO DO.
AND DID DID TEAR THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF REMOVING HOUSING
FROM HOUSING STOCK AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE STATE COMMUNITIES
STRUGGLING TO GET BY.
AND PROVIDE HOUSING FOR THEIR
RENTERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
TO WITNESSES DEAL CARLSON
FOUNDER SHARE BETTER.
ASSTAFF AND CONSULTED ON THE
HOUSING PULSES WITH A NUMBER OF
LABOR AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS JOHN
CALLED WILL OF CALIFORNIA HOTEL
AND LODGING ASSOCIATION ALL
TURNED OVER TO THEM.
THANK GOD I'M GONNA GIVE THE
WITNESSES AND IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL IN THE WITNESSES WHO OPPOSE
THE BILL EIGHT MINUTES TOTAL SO
YOU CAN DIVIDE THAT UP HOWEVER
YOU'D LIKE.
VERY WELL THANK YOU.
I AM BILL CARLSON I'M CO FOUNDER
OF SHARE BETTER SF.
THE COALITION OF A RATHER
DISPARATE INTERESTS -- MY
COALITION REPRESENTS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS. TEN
ORGANIZATIONS LANDLORD
ASSOCIATIONS HOTELS THE HOTEL
WORKERS UNION.
AND NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS FROM
BOTH THE EAST AND WEST SIDES OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND IF YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
SAN FRANCISCO POLITICS IT'S
PRETTY DIFFICULT TO GET ALL
THOSE PARTIES TOGETHER ON ONE
ISSUE.
THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF AIRBNB IT
BRINGS TOGETHER VERY DISPARATE
ELEMENTS.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO REIN IN THE
PROLIFERATION OF SHORT TERM
RENTALS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHEN I BEGAN
THIS EXERCISE.
THERE WERE THIRTEEN THOUSAND
LISTINGS ON THE TOP THREE
PLATFORMS ALONE AND WE HAD SIXTY
WEBSITES OFFERING SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL RENTALS TO TOURISTS.
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED ONE PLATFORM
ACCOUNTABILITY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
LEFT TO THEIR OWN DEVICES AIRBNB
THE RPO HOME AWAY WILL RENT
ANYTHING.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S REGISTERED REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S LEGAL.
WITH OR WITHOUT AN OWNER'S.
PERMISSION AND EVEN OVER AN
OWNER'S EXPLICIT OBJECTIONS.
SO PLATFORM ACCOUNTABILITY
BECOME CENTRAL. TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ANY REGULATION
WHEN WE ADOPTED IN IN IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
THE NUMBER OF AIRBNB OPERATORS
IN THE CITY DROPPED.
FROM EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED TO LESS
THAN.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED I WANT TO TALK
SECOND ABOUT TERM.
AND THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS THAT
ARE OFTEN ASCRIBED TO SHORT TERM
RENTALS.
EVERY INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS OF
BEEN UNDERTAKEN IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS HAS FOUND THE SAME THING.
THEIR OVER INFLATED.
I WATCH THIS MORNING AS THE CO
FOUNDER OF AIRBNB BRAG THAT HIS
COMPANY HAD -- COLLECTED AND
REMITTED A BILLION DOLLARS IN
HOTEL TAXES IN THE PAST TEN
YEARS TWO FIVE HUNDRED AMERICAN
CITIES A BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY.
UNTIL YOU CONSIDER THAT SAN
FRANCISCO HOTELS ALONE.
GENERATE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR.
JUST IN THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE SHORT TERMINAL PLATFORMS
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
SPENDING THAT THERE ARE
[inaudible]
CUSTOMERS -- THE MONEY THAT THE
CUSTOMER SPENDING IN IN CITIES
THANKS TO SHORT TERM RENTALS.
BUT AGAIN THE SURVEYS FIND THAT
ONLY 224% OF THOSE DOLLARS ARE
NEW DOLLARS.
THERE'S A DOLLARS IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN SPENT ABSENT THE SHORT TERM
RENTALS THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
SPENT BY PEOPLE STAYING IN
HOTELS AND BED AND BREAKFASTS
AND MOTELS.
AND TRADITIONAL TOURIST
ACCOMMODATIONS.
SAN FRANCISCO'S CHIEF ECONOMIST
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED LOOKING AT
THIS ISSUE.
DETERMINED THAT FOR EVERY UNIT.
CONVERTED TO A FULL TIME SHORT
TERM RENTAL.
EVERY UNIT COST THE CITY
225-200-52300 THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN LOST ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
TOURISTS DON'T SPEND THE WAY
RESIDENTS SPENT.
DOORS DON'T GET THEIR HAIR CUT
THEY DON'T GO TO THE HARDWARE
STORE THEY DON'T.
GO TO THE DRY CLEANERS THEY
DON'T SUPPORT THE NEIGHBORHOOD
SERVING BUSINESSES THAT MAKE A
NEIGHBORHOOD A NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND AND AND THOSE NEIGHBORHOOD
SERVING BUSINESSES ARE DOUBLY
IMPACTED.
WHEN HOUSING BECOMES LESS
AVAILABLE AND LESS AFFORDABLE
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES?
IF I CAME TO YOU.
IF ANYONE CAME TO YOU AND
PROPOSED DEMOLISHING. FOURTEEN
THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING.
IN CITIES IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
COASTAL CITIES IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND NOT REPLACING THEM.
YOU THINK I WAS NUTS.
THEN I WOULD BE.
BUT THAT'S EFFECTIVELY WHAT'S
HAPPENED.
THE NUMBER OF SHORT TERM RENTALS
IN SAN DIEGO IS GROWING.
A RATHER DRAMATIC PACE IT'S UP
50% IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO GROW.
UNLESS SOMETHING IS DONE TO REIN
IN IN.
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY IS WORKING
OVERTIME. TO FIND WAYS TO
ACCELERATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING [inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU OUGHT TO BE WORKING EQUALLY
HARD TO PRESERVE THE HOUSING
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON UP JOHN CALDWELL
BEHALF CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION JUST A LITTLE BIT
BACK ON THE ISSUE WE'RE DEALING
WITH HERE.
WHEN MOST PEOPLE THINK OF AIRBNB
OR SHORT TERM RENTALS -- THEY
THINK OF HOME SHARING THE COUPLE
THAT RETIRED COUPLE WHO LET OUT
THEIR HOUSE EVERY SO OFTEN TO
EARN SOME SIDE MONEY WE HEAR
THAT STORY ALL THE TIME.
HOME SHARING IS NOT THE PROBLEM
NOT TO US NOT TO THE AUTHOR.
THE PROBLEM IS WHAT THE NEW YORK
ATTORNEY GENERAL ONCE CALLED
COMMERCIAL USERS.
A FEW YEARS AGO WE GOT THE
RECORDS OF AIRBNB IN NEW YORK
CITY HE FOUND THAT
DISPROPORTIONATE.
SHARE OF THE UNITS WERE OWNED BY
COMMERCIAL USERS HE FOUND THAT
FOR EXAMPLE TWELVE POSTPONED
EIGHT HUNDRED UNITS AND
ACCOUNTED FOR TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN RENT IN ONE
YEAR -- THAT WAS TWENTY FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO STUDY BY AIR
DE ANY ERROR DNA WHICH IS TRACK
SERBIAN BEES -- LISTINGS AND
REVENUE FOUND THAT ONLY 25%.
OF AIRBNB IS REVENUE IN NEW YORK
AND SAN FRANCISCO COMES FROM
HOME SHARING.
IN IN LA IT'S 19% THE OTHER 81%
IS COMMERCIAL.
SO THE ISSUE HERE IS NOT HOME
SHARING AND TAKING AWAY PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO PLAN OUT THEIR WHOLE
HOUSE EVERY SO OFTEN.
THE PROBLEM WITH THESE
COMMERCIAL USERS ARE.
THEY THEY PRESENT A BUNCH OF
PROBLEMS BILL ONE IS THERE
CREATING WHAT I'M AMOUNTS TO
ILLEGAL HOTELS.
AND IS CLEARLY HAVING A NEGATIVE
INCOME IMPACT ON ON HOUSING --
APARTMENTS -- APARTMENTS AND
HOMES ARE BEING TAKEN OFF THE
LONG TERM RENTAL MARKET -- A
UNITE HERE OFFICIAL TOLD ME.
THAT HOTEL EMPLOYEES ALL OVER
THE STATE ARE FINDING THEY HAVE.
TO MOVE FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY
FROM THEIR JOBS.
JUST BECAUSE FORMALLY AFFORDABLE
HOMES AND APARTMENTS ARE NO
LONGER AVAILABLE -- THEN THERE'S
WE TALKED ABOUT THE THE THE
PROVISION TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LOCAL TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAXES
ARE PAID.
NOW T. O. T. IS FOR THOSE FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT NO IT'S ONE OF
THE FEW REVENUE STREAMS THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
HAVE WITHOUT LIMITS.
SHORT TERM RENTALS SHOULD PAY
THAT TAX THEY DON'T -- THAT PUTS
LEGITIMATE HOTELS AND BED AND
BREAKFAST -- AT A SIGNIFICANT
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE FOR
EXAMPLE AND THE CHAIRS TOWN OF
HOMETOWN OF GLENDALE -- THEY'LL
TEAR 212% -- SO ALL THINGS BEING
EQUAL TO COST 12% MORE TO STAY
AT A HOTEL IN BED AND BREAKFAST.
IT ALSO DENIES CITIES AND
COUNTIES A LOT OF NEEDED REVENUE
WHICH IS WHAT WHY THIS BILL
MANDATES THAT THE PLATFORM
COLLECT.
IN A CLICK THE T. O. T. THAT
IT'S OWED.
NOT AIRBNB SAYS THEY HAVE
NUMEROUS CONTRACTS TO CITIES ALL
OVER THE STATE WHICH THEY
COLLECT THE T. O. T. FOR THEIR
HOSTS BUT THEY WILL ONLY DO THAT
UNDER THE THEIR CONDITIONS
THEY'LL NEVER TELL YOU THIS.
THE CITY OR THE COUNTY WHERE THE
RENTAL UNITS ARE LOCATED WHO
OWNS THEM OR HOW MANY NIGHTS
THEY WERE OCCUPIED HERE BE JUST
SENSE THE CITY COUNTY A CHECK
AND SAYS TRUST ME.
IF THE CITY WANTED ME TO THOSE
CONDITIONS THEY WILL GET THE TOT.
BED AND BREAKFAST AND HOTELS IN
EVERY CITY ND THE COUNTY AND
COUNTY IN THE STATE ON THE OTHER
HAND ARE REGULARLY AUDITED TO
DETERMINE THE EXACT AMOUNT OF
TOT OWED.
SO THIS BILL LIMITS NOT BANDS
SHORT TERM RENTALS BY COMMERCIAL
HOSTS IN ONE COUNTY IN THE
COASTAL ZONE FOR A FEW YEARS.
AND IT SHOULD BE ADDED THAT THE
AUTHORS WRITTEN THE BILL SO IT
WILL NOT IMPACT THOSE WHO JUST
SHARE THEIR OWN HOMES.
WE'RE CHEN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER -- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WANTS TO USE A VOICE
OR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD AND JUST
NAME AND AFFILIATION OF ANY
WHETHER OR NOT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON DEBORAH
KERR THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
MATT BROUGHT FOR YOU KNOW HERE
IN TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT.
SEAN DRAKE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION THE
COMMISSION DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION BUT I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR INCLUDING
US IN THE CONVERSATIONS ON THESE
ISSUES.
Q. ANYWAY THIS IS AN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME UP TO THE TABLE.
AND AGAIN I WILL GIVE THE
CONTENTS ARE EIGHT COMBINED
MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS JOHN A MECHANIC ON
THE PRESIDENT SHARE SAN DIEGO
WHICH IS A GROUP OF HUNDREDS OF
POSTS.
HOMEOWNERS AND PROPERTY MANAGERS
THROUGHOUT SAN DIEGO.
WHO RELY ON VACATION RENTALS TO
MAKE ENDS MEET?
WELL BEFORE THE INTERNET.
FAMILIES BEEN RENTING HOMES ON
THE BEACH TO ENJOY THEIR
VACATIONS IN A PRIVATE SPACE
THAT ALLOWS AN AFFORDABLE WAY
FOR ENTIRE FAMILY TO GET
TOGETHER.
AND MAKE MEMORIES.
THE TWO MET THE TWO TO THREE
MINUTES I HAVE TODAY.
ALLOWS ME TO SCRATCH THE SURFACE
AS TO WHY AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE WOULD ESSENTIALLY BANNED
THESE TYPES OF RENTALS AND SAN
DIEGO.
BUT I WILL DO MY BEST. FOR YEARS
SHARE SAN DIEGO HAS WORKED
CLOSELY WITH OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AN EFFORT
TO CREATE NOORDIN'S ELIMINATES A
BAD ACTORS FROM THE SHARING
ECONOMY WHILE PROTECTING THOSE A
PLAY BY THE RULES.
ALLOW THE USE AND STOP THE ABUSE
HAS BEEN A PHRASE THAT HAS BEEN
USED TIME TIME AGAIN.
AB SEVEN THIRTY THIRTY ONE DOES
THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
IT TARGETS A PLATFORM TO DO
FOLLOW THE RULES AND ENHANCES
THE PLATFORMS THAT FOSTER THE
BAD ACTORS.
LET ME FURTHER EXPLAIN.
IN CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY PLATFORMS LIKE
AIRBNB HOMEAWAY ENVY RPO WORK
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS AND
HOMEOWNERS TO HELP CRAFT
REGULATION.
THAT MEETS LOCAL NEEDS IN MANY
CASES PLATFORMS ENDORSED
SIGNIFICANT LIMITS ON SHORT TERM
RENTALS THESE ARE THE GOOD
ACTORS.
LIMITING THE EXPOSURE THESE
PLATFORMS CAN HAVE TO JUST
THIRTY DAYS EACH DOES NOTHING
POSITIVE AND ONLY ENCOURAGES
HOST TO LIST ON COUNTLESS OTHER
PLATFORMS THAT ARE UNMONITORED.
UNREGULATED AND DO NOT COLLECT
NOR PAY CITY TAXES.
IF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WERE
TO PASS IT WOULD END UP COSTING
CITIES HUNDREDS OF MILLION
DOLLARS OF LOST TAX REVENUE.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE DOES
EXACTLY OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING TOWARDS FOR YEARS
IT DISCOURAGES HOSTS FROM USING
RESPONSIBLE PLATFORMS AND PUSHES
THEM TOWARDS THE IRRESPONSIBLE.
ON MANNERED SHE'S ME UNMONITORED
AND UNENFORCEABLE PLATFORMS.
SECONDLY IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THIS BILL FOCUSES ON
SEVERELY RESTRICTING IF NOT
COMPLETELY ELIMINATING ANY HOME
FROM SHORT TERM RENTAL INVENTORY
THAT IS NOT A PRIMARY RESIDENCE.
I RESPECTFULLY CHALLENGE THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TO
ADVISE US WHAT THIS ACTUALLY
MEANS.
HAS ANY RESEARCH BEEN DONE OR
ANY DATA COLLECTED.
REGARDING HOW MANY HOMES WOULD
BE ELIMINATED AS A RESULT.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE CURRENT
SHORT TERM RENTAL INVENTORY
WOULD QUALIFY AS A PRIMARY
RESIDENCE AND WHAT PERCENTAGE AS
A SECONDARY HOME?
WITH THIS BILL I'M AT 85% OF THE
INVENTORY OR 95% OF THE
INVENTORY.
ABOUT HOTEL OCCUPANCY EXCUSE ME
OCCUPANCY IN SAN DIEGO WHAT IS
THE OCCUPANCY RATE AND WHAT IS
THE VACANCY RATE.
IF X. AMOUNT OF HOMES WERE
ELIMINATED SHORT TERM RENTALS
WOULD THERE EVEN BE ENOUGH HOTEL
ROOMS TO PROVIDE ACCOMMODATIONS
TO TOURISTS TO OUR BEACHES AND
BASS.
IF THIS THAT IS NOT KNOWN IN THE
AFFECTED THIS BILL WOULD HAVE ON
AVAILABILITY TO OUR VISITORS IS
ALSO UNKNOWN AND US IN DIRECT
CONFLICT OF THE CALIFORNIA COAST
SELECT WHICH SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSES ON PRESERVING AND
PROTECTING.
LOW COST VISITORS ACCOMMODATION
ACROSS OUR BEACHES AND BASS.
I HEAR FROM I GUESS ALL THE TIME
HOW THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
AFFORD A BEACH VACATION IF THEY
HAD TO RENT MULTIPLE HOTEL ROOMS.
TO FIT THEIR FAMILIES OF
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS PER NIGHT.
SHORT TERM RENTALS PROVIDE AN
AFFORDABLE OPTION FOR PEOPLE TO
VISIT THE BEACH AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROTECT THAT
RIGHT.
OUR LOCAL ECONOMY WOULD BE
HUGELY IMPACTED IF A BILL LIKE
THIS PASTLOCAL BUSINESSES IN
OUR COMMUNITY BENEFIT FROM SHORT
TERM RENTALS AS WE PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR LOCAL RENTAL
COMPANIES.
RESTAURANTS IN ACTIVITY
OPERATORS FOR GUESTS THROUGHOUT
THEIR STAY.
HELPING TO ENSURE ALL OF SAN
DIEGO BENEFITS FROM OUR VISITORS.
IF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WERE
TO PASS MANY BEDS BUSINESSES
WOULD SUFFER.
INSTEAD OF BANNING VACATION
RENTALS AND LIMITING ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA BEACHES WE SHOULD
EMBRACE SHORT TERM RENTALS AS
LOW COST ACCOMMODATION OPTIONS.
IN DOING SO WE PROTECT PRESERVE
ACCESS TO THE COAST AND PROTECT
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS
TAXPAYERS AND THE COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE IS NOT THE ANSWER.
AS A VOTER IRISH OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS INDUSTRY IN SAN
DIEGO FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
KAMALA WAGNER REPRESENTING
HIGHLIGHT OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL.
FIRST EVEN IN ITS AMENDED FORM
WE REMAIN VERY CONCERNED THAT
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WILL
RESTRICT ACCESS TO THE CODES FOR
INDIVIDUALS LOOKING FOR
AFFORDABLE ACCOMMODATIONS WHEN
TRAVELING WITH FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY UCLA AND
THE COASTAL COMMISSION FOUND
THAT AFFORDABLE OVERNIGHT
ACCOMMODATIONS IS ONE OF THE
MAIN BARRIERS FOR VISITING THE
COAST.
APPROXIMATELY 75% OF UCLA SURVEY
PARTICIPANTS CITED THIS CONCERN
WITH A HIGHER RATE OF LATINO
VOTERS AND FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN CITING THIS AS A BIG
PROBLEM.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE AVERAGE
NIGHTLY PRICE PAID FOR AIRBNB
RENTALS WAS NINETY FIVE DOLLARS
PER PERSON WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY DOLLARS
LOWER THAN THE AVERAGE RATE IN
THE COASTAL ZONE.
AND THIRTY DOLLARS LOWER DURING
THE SUMMER SEASON PER PERSON.
THIS BILL BY ALLOWING CITIES TO
PUT EVEN STRICTER LIMITS IN
PLACE WILL UNDOUBTEDLY LEAD TO
LESS ACCESS BY THESE FAMILIES TO
THE COAST.
SECOND THE BILL PUTS HOSTING
PLATFORMS IN THE MIDDLE OF
TENANT AND PROPERTY OWNER
AGREEMENTS BY REQUIRING
PLATFORMS TO VERIFY THAT A
TENANT HAS PERMISSION BEFORE
LISTING THEIR HOME.
THIS IS UNTENABLE AND COMPLETELY
UNWORKABLE CONSIDERING THAT SOME
PROPERTY OWNERS MAY BE LOCATED
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE AND
OFTENTIMES OUTSIDE OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THESE
AGREEMENT SHOULD REMAIN BETWEEN
A TENANT AND AN OWNER.
THIRD AIRBNB AS WAS STATED HAS
NEGOTIATED -- VOLUNTARY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS WITH
SEVERAL CITIES IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY TO COLLECT DOT JUST
RECENTLY INCLUDING WITH THE CITY
OF OCEANSIDE.
AND LET ME POINT OUT THAT ALL
CONTRACTS NEGOTIATED -- FOR TOT
COLLECTION ALLOW FOR AUDITS BY
THE CITY.
THIS BILL WILL LIKELY REDUCE THE
REVENUE THAT SOME OF THE CITIES
ARE ALREADY RECEIVING ESPECIALLY
IF THE CITY NOW ALLOWS MORE DAYS
FOR VACATION HOMES TO BE RENTED.
THAN WHAT THE BILL WOULD ALLOW.
LASTLY WE WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT THE EXISTING LOCAL
PROCESS CAN WORK HAS WORKED AND
IS WORKING.
SOME LOCAL ORDINANCES WERE
APPROVED UPON INITIAL COASTAL
COMMISSION REVIEW AND SOME MORE
AMENDED BECAUSE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION ARGUED THAT NOT
ENOUGH ACCESS WAS BEING PROVIDED.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE CRAFTED
ORDINANCES THAT REFLECT THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND WE CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
UNNECESSARY.
WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
OR TO VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
MY NAME IS NANCY KRAMER I'VE
BEEN IN THE VACATION RENTAL
AGENCY BUSINESS FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND I FLEW ALL THE WAY
HERE TO LET YOU KNOW THAT I
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS
HEALY GOVERNOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU TO READ ON
THE A SHORT TERM RENTER OWNER OF
A PROPERTY IN SAN DIEGO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THIS DOES
NOTHING TO PROTECT THE COASTLINE.
JUST PROTECTS WHO HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT IT.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
VOICE THEIR OPINION ABOUT THE
BILL.
OKAY SING NOT I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
YES IF IF I COULD.
IF IF THE AUTHOR COULD.
IF EXPLAIN TO BE THE LOCAL
PROCESS AND WHY THAT
INSUFFICIENT AND AND STILL DOES
YOUR PROPOSING THE BILL.
SURE THIS BILL ACTUALLY
MAINTAINS LOCAL CONTROL -- IN
THE ISSUE OF THE FACT THAT --
FULL TIME SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS ARE REMOVING HOUSING
FROM OUR HOUSING MARKET AND WE
HAVE DETERMINED AS A LEGISLATURE
THAT THE HOUSING PRICES OF
STATEWIDE IMPORTANCE IMPORTANCE.
AND SO IN ADDRESSING THAT AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTY -- THIS BILL
WOULD ABSOLUTELY ALLOW LOCAL
CONTROL TO CONTINUE IF AS A
LOCAL JURISDICTION ONE TO ZONE
THE AN AREA RESIDENTIAL TOURISM.
WHICH EXPLICITLY ALLOWS IT IT
WOULD BE THAT THE ALLOWS LOCAL
CONTROL -- I OF WHERE OF THOSE --
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM ZONES ARE --
AND THE OTHER THING IS YOU KNOW
THE THE THE NETWORK AROUND SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS AND THE
CAUSES OF THIS PARTICULARLY
COMPLEX.
BECAUSE YOU DO OF THE COSTA
COMMISSION -- INVOLVED AT THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
YOU HAVE THE PLATFORMS OPERATE
OUTSIDE OF THAT -- AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY OWNERS AND
SO WE TRY TO CRAFT A PATH OF
THIS BILL THAT PRESERVES
PROPERTY RIGHTS I THINK AS ONE
OF THE OPPONENTS EVEN STATED.
LONG BEFORE THERE WAS AIRBNB --
FOLKS ARE RENTING OUT SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS AND ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT THEY DID BEFORE
AIRBNB CAN STILL HAPPEN AND ARE
NOT REGULATED AND ANYWAY BY THIS
BILL.
THIS BILL ONLY REGULATES THE
PROP PLATFORMS THE NUMBER OF
DAYS THAT A UNIT CAN BE RENTED
OVER THE PLATFORM IN THE COASTAL
ZONE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY BECAUSE
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS AND
THESE UNITS -- THE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL PLATFORMS ARE
AMPLIFYING OF THE REMOVAL OF
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS FROM --
OUR HOUSING MARKET AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO NOTE THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND IS THIS THE PILOT
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY HAS ABOUT ONE PER.
ONE THOUSAND A LOW COST IN OUR
LOW COST ACCOMMODATION RIGHT ARE
NOT LOW COST COMPETITION
ACCOMMODATION RATE AND THAT'S IN
THE BECAUSE THE COMMISSION'S OWN
REPORT.
SO WE'RE ALREADY DOING A GOOD
JOB OF PROVIDING ACCESS TO THE
COAST AND AGAIN I LIKE TO
REITERATE THAT THIS BILL
ABSOLUTELY ALLOWS FOR THE
OCCASIONAL HOME SHARE THE PERSON
WHO'S ON SITE TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO THE COAST.
I GUESS WELL WELL TWO THINGS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THAT CLEAN
MADE ITS INTENTION IT'S CLEAR
THAT WE NEED TO BE ADDRESSING
THE HOUSING SHORTAGE. FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WE'VE ALSO
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ACCESS TO THE
COAST FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
INLAND COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE.
AND A LODGING BEING ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE BEARS THAT WE TRY TO
TALK ABOUT HER AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S I THINK BOTH
ISSUES.
HAVE HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE TO
BE DISCUSSES THE PRIORITY BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND WHAT I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
THIS.
UNDERSTANDING WHERE THE HOW THIS
BALANCE IS STILL FOR TWO PIECES
AND THE PART OF MY QUESTION IS
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
CURRENTLY A LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN
GO TO THE CLOSE THE COMMISSION.
TO TRY TO PASS REGULATIONS
DEALING WITH OUR VACATION
RENTALS.
WHY IS THAT NOT SUFFICIENT IS MY
QUESTION SO THE BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION I THINK IT WAS A DONE
BY THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS VERY
ASTUTELY -- THE BECAUSE
COMMISSION ONLY AS PER VIEW OVER
ACCESS TO THE COAST THEY DO NOT
HAVE PER VIEW OVER BALANCING.
THE IMPACT ON RENTAL PRICES FOR
EXAMPLE -- FOR THOSE WHO LIVE
THERE SO A SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL ORDINANCE THAT WOULD NOT
BE REVIEWED UNDER THE COSTA
COMMISSIONS PER VIEW OF WHAT IS
THE FACT ON HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY FROM THAT --
ORDNANCE.
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
OF ALLOWING BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION TO STILL HAVE THEIR
RIGHT -- OVER AND EVALUATING THE
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
ORDINANCES AND MAKING SURE
THEY'RE ENSURING ACCESS TO THE
COAST WHICH THEY DO IN EVERY
SINGLE ORDINANCE IN.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY -- AND THEN
CAPPING WHAT'S THIS
AMPLIFICATION BECAUSE AS I
SHARED BEFORE YOU GOT HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- YOU KNOW AN
ID WE HAVE A CASE OF TWO HUNDRED
UNITS.
IT JUST WHAT IT JUST GOT
COMPLETED AND AN EIGHT OF THEM
ARE ALREADY FULL TIME SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS.
THAT CITY AB DOES NOT HAVE A
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
CRISIS THAT CITY HAS A HOUSING
CRISIS.
AND THIS IS THE STRAW STRUGGLE
THAT WE ALL HAVE AND SO -- I I
TAKE THE CITY OF CROSS BUT THE
CITY OF CARLSBAD THEY WOULD HAVE
BANNED THE SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS ENTIRELY ON THEIR CITY.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A GROWTH
MANAGEMENT PLAN AND THEY ARE ON
TRACK FOR MAKING SURE THEY REACH
THEIR HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
GOALS.
AND THEY WERE REQUIRED TO PUT IT
IN THERE -- WHICH IS NOT BAD WE
WANT TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE COAST --
BUT THIS IS AMPLIFYING IT TO THE
POINT WHERE DEVELOPERS ARE GOING
IN AND LOOKING TO LOOK USE OUR
STATE WIDE STREAMLINING MEASURES
THAT WE'RE PASSING. TO BUILD A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AND
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
ZONES AND CONVERTING THEM TO
FULL TIME SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS BECAUSE THEY THINK THEY
CAN MAKE MORE MONEY WITH.
THIS IS THE REALITY REALITY SO
IF WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS WE
DEAL WITH THAT WE STOP THE
BLEEDING FIRST.
AND THEN WE GO AHEAD AND AND
ADDRESS A YOU KNOW HOW WE STILL
HAVE TO BUILD MORE HOUSING
CLEARLY YOU KNOW.
AND I WOULD ST WITH YOUR EXAMPLE --
75% OF THOSE UNITS FOR FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND TWENTY
FIVE WERE SET ASIDE FOR THE
CERTIFICATION IT'S THE IDEA THAT
WE WE MULTI TASK HERE WE HAVE.
TO YOU KNOW TALK ABOUT COMPETING
INTERESTS AT TIMES OUT THERE --
AND I I DON'T KNOW.
THE THEY'RE THEY'RE BOTH EQUALLY
IMPORTANT -- I KNOW THAT AIRBNB
IS SOMETHING THAT I USE -- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT MAKE CONSTITUENTS
ON THE RARE OCCASION THAT THEY
CAN MAKE IT HAPPEN THIS EVEN
THEN THEY CAN'T MAKE IT HAPPEN
VERY OFTEN.
SOMETHING THAT THAT THAT THEY
USE OUT THERE AND SO AXIS IS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT WHEN I'M WE'RE
SITTING HERE WAITING ON
LEGISLATION REMIXES JUST LIKE
WHY DO YOU CARE ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE READY CARE ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE COAST NONE OF
THAT AFFECTS ME AND IT AND
THEY'RE NOT CONNECTED. TO IT AND
THAT'S PART OF THAT ACCESS SO
THAT.
I COULD EASILY TO THEM THE
BIGGER ECOSYSTEM AND HOW IT IS
CONNECTED THE SOMETIMES THE ONLY
WAY TO DO IT IF I TAKING THEM OR
HAVING THEM HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE
THERE -- THANK YOU FOR FOR
YASSER STILL SO AND I APPRECIATE
THIS TO BE CLEAR THE IB EXAMPLE.
TWENTY FIVE OF THOSE UNITS WERE
NOT SET ASIDE FOR SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE -- TWO HUNDRED
RENTAL UNITS -- PERMANENTLY AND
I'D BE AND TWENTY FIVE OF THOSE
TWO HUNDRED ARE NOW FULL TIME
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO NEED TO
HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD.
IN SOUTH SAN DIEGO COUNTY THEY
DON'T HAVE ONE AND THE OTHER
THING IS I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT WHEN WHEN AIRBNB SAYS.
THAT THEY HAVE RUN OUT ON
AVERAGE OF NINETY FIVE NIGHT
THAT'S CALCULATING FOR PEOPLE I
BELIEVE PER ROOM AND THAT'S
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A NIGHT
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT YOU BUT WHEN
MY FAMILY GOES STAYS AT THE
IKANA LOGINH ANTHONY THIS FOR
EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS A NIGHT.
WE ALL YOU KNOW BUNDLE UP AND
FOR PEOPLE IN ONE HOTEL ROOM FOR
EIGHTY NINE AT NIGHT.
SO JUST -- TO GIVE SOME -- YOU
KNOW CONTACTS FOR OTHER PRICING
IN IN THE DISTRICT [inaudible]
MR FLORA.
SAYED DON'T REALLY KNOW SO I
HAVE A QUESTION BUT I CERTAINLY
ECHO SO LITERACY IS COMMENTS --
THERE ARE SOME GREAT CONCERNS
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE OF US TO
LIVE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
YOU KNOW IT TO ME THIS SOUNDS
LIKE A VERY MUCH A SUPPLY DEMAND
ISSUE.
THAT IF THERE IS A DEMAND EVEN
IF THERE ARE INVESTORS THAT ARE
INVESTING IN THESE HOMES CLEARLY
THERE IS A DEMAND.
AND SO IF THERE IS PEOPLE THAT
ARE WANTING TO GO TO THE COAST
THERE NEEDING PLACES TO STAY.
WE SHOULD PROVIDE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
SO IF WE CUT THE AVAILABLE ROOMS
WHATEVER THEY MAY BE.
OBVIOUSLY THE PRICE IS GOING UP
THEY'RE GONNA CHARGE MORE FOR
THAT SO WE CREATE THIS ACCESS
ISSUE AND IF YOU DO GET LUCKY
AND BE ABLE TO GET SOMEBODY.
YOU HAVE AG PRICING PROBLEM
WHERE A LOT OF MY CONSTITUENTS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD THAT.
SO THIS THING TO ME -- I DON'T
LIKE THE FACT THAT WE'RE TELLING
PEOPLE WHAT TO DO WITH THE
PRIVATE PROPERTY I DON'T
PARTICULARLY LOVE THAT.
BUT FOR ME IT'S IT'S AND WE
WANNA TALK ABOUT EQUITY ALL DAY
LONG IN THIS BUILDING.
OKAY WE DON'T LIVE ON THE COAST
WERE FARM COUNTRY WE LIKE TO
VISIT.
I'VE TRIED TO GET HOTEL ROOMS
AND SAN DIEGO WHEN THERE'S
CONVENTIONS GOING ON AND GUESS
WHAT WE'RE BEING BE AN BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO HOTELS AVAILABLE.
SO THIS IS A HUGE CONCERN OF
MINE AND I DO WANNA -- KNOWS THE
OPPOSITION WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE RATES -- JUST LIKE YOU
MAYBE TO HEAR YOUR COMMENTS ON
SOME OF THOSE RATES AND HOW
ROOMS THE RATES ARE SET A
PARTICULAR ROOMS AS A RELEASED
ACCURACY.
CERTAINLY -- DO HAVE A TIME
LIMIT I A MINUTE ALL THE START.
UP TO THE CHAIR.
REVIEWS YOU CAN MAKE IT IS VERY
COMPETITION ALL TRY TO I CAN
TALK ABOUT THIS STUFF ALL DAY --
I I AM PRIMARILY BY THE COAST I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE TALK
ABOUT RATES TO FACTOR IN THE THE
WHOLE EQUATION WHEN YOU SAID A
HOTEL YOU PAY FOR PARKING YOU
PAY FOR INTERNET USAGE YOU PAY
YOUR ROOM.
YOU PAY A HOTEL RESORT FEE --
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU ALSO PAY
FOR YOUR NIGHTLY RATE -- YES
RATES ARE SUBSTANTIALLY CHEAPER
WHEN YOU DIVIDE THEM BY ROOM IF
YOU'RE FOR EXAMPLE LOOKING AT A
TWO BEDROOM CONDO IN MISSION
BEACH AS OPPOSED TO TRYING TO
GET IF YOU CAN EVEN FIND -- ONE
TO HOTEL ROOMS AT A LOCAL HOTEL
THERE IS NO COMPARISON BUT
FACTORED INTO THAT THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE A KITCHEN.
THAT YOU CAN THEN COOK YOUR OWN
MEALS -- WHICH FOR A LOT OF OUR
GUESTS ARE STAYING WITH FAMILIES
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT -- YOU
KNOW THE THE THAT IS THE NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER TWO REASON WE
HEAR FROM OUR GAS WHY THEY WANT.
TO STAY IN A SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL AS OPPOSED TO A HOTEL
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE KIDS --
YOU WOULD MUCH PREFER TO COOK
YOUR OWN MEALS YOU SAVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY AND
IT IS MUCH CHEAPER AND TACKLE
YOUR POINTS ARE FROM GOING TOO
QUICKLY.
IS THAT ALONG THE COAST AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I CAN TELL
YOU YOU CANNOT FIND A HOTEL ROOM
THERE IS NO AVAILABILITY I MEAN
WE HAVE PEOPLE HERE FROM THE
HOTEL INDUSTRY I WOULD BE
CURIOUS TO SEE.
WHAT THEY'RE VACANCY RATES ARE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR HOTEL
ROOMS WHETHER PD CONNELL LODGE --
Là BALENCIAGA THERE ARE NO
HOTEL ROOMS HOTELS ARE
COMPLETELY SOLD OUT AND TO YOUR
POINT.
IF YOU LIMIT THE AVAILABILITY OF
SHORT TERM RENTALS DRASTICALLY
WHICH THIS WOULD BY MY
CALCULATIONS BY 9295% OF COURSE
RATES HOTEL RATES ARE GONNA GO
UP AS TALK AS VACANCY GOES.
UP AND IS AVAILABILITY GOES DOWN
THEN RATES GO UP SO IT IS NO
SURPRISE THAT THOSE THAT ARE.
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING THIS BILL
ARE PRIMARILY FROM THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY.
I HAVE TO JUST SAY I I DRAFTED
THIS BILL MYSELF BECAUSE THIS IS
A CRISIS IN MY COMMUNITY THIS IS
A CRISIS PEOPLE DO NOT.
THEY THEY CANNOT FIND SOMEWHERE
AFFORDABLE TO RENT AND YES
THERE'S A SUPPLY PROBLEM
ABSOLUTELY THERE'S MORE WE HAVE
TO BUILD.
BUT WHEN WE ARE BLEEDING OUT
UNIT AFTER UNIT AFTER UNIT.
YOU KNOW WE ARE NOT ADDRESSING
THE SUPPLY PROBLEM ON OUT WE'RE
NOT ADDRESSING PRESERVING WHAT'S
HERE AND I THINK ONE OF MY
WITNESSES SAID THIS BUT WE'RE
AFFECTIVELY DEMOLISHING UNITS
AND NOT REPLACING THEM FOR A
HOUSING MARKET.
AND I RESPECT THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WANT TO COME TO SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND STATE AND WE
HAVE MANY PROVISIONS OF THIS
THIS IS JUST CAMP CAPPING THE
AMPLIFICATION OF THE SUMMER I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU A ABILITY TO
CLOSE.
SO I'M JUST GONNA LET THE
COMMITTEE MINISH ASKING
QUESTIONS THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU
YOU ARE THE WITNESSES.
BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT I MEAN I I
DO WANT TO PAUSE FOR SECOND WAS
I WAS A QUORUM.
WE CAN TAKE ROLL CALL.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HERE FRIEDMAN
HERE FLORA FLOOR HERE CHAU
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GARCIA GARCIA HERE
LIMóN MATHIS.
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY MELENDEZ
MURATSUCHI STONE [inaudible]
SHOWN HERE.
THANK YOU HAVE A QUORUM -- SO AT
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THEN
[inaudible]
MR MATHIS [inaudible]
I LOOKED.
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
EVERYWHERE IT'S NOT JUST SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SAN DIEGO COUNTY IS
NOT EVEN THAT TOP TWENTY
COUNTIES THAT ARE GROWING.
IN THE STATE.
WHERE I MET IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WERE GROWING FASTER?
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
GATEWAY TO THIS YEAR AS AN AND
QUITE FRANKLY I'M NOT RUNNING A
BILL TO BLOCK AIRBNB.
RENTALS FOR THE GATEWAY OF THE
SIERRAS IN WE FRESNO EVERYBODY
GOING UP IN THE U. SOMEBODY.
THE HOTEL GET PACKED THEIR TO SO.
IT'S TO ME I'M JUST REALLY
TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW I OTHERS SHARE THE
STORY THE AND I'M A HOST AT FOR
A FOREIGN EXCHANGE STUDENT THIS
YEAR.
AND WE HAD FIFTEEN FOR EXCHANGE
STUDENTS THE WANTED TO GO DOWN
TO DISNEYLAND.
AS AS PART OF THEIR BUCKET LIST
FOR WEATHER HERE.
AND WE LOOKED AT HOTELS.
IN THE COSTA HOTELS.
WAS MORE THAN THE COST FOR
AIRBNB.
DOWN THERE [inaudible]
AND THERE'S NO WAY WE'RE OING
TO FIT FIFTEEN STUDENTS.
PLUS THE CHAPERONES.
AND EVERYBODY ELSE IN A HOTEL.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
YOUR WILL FINING AIRBNB FOR TWO
HUNDRED BUCKS A NIGHT AND WE'RE
ABLE TO COOK FOR THEM.
IN ENSURE THEY HAD SOMETHING
GOOD TO EAT WHERE THEY WERE
GOING TO BLOW ALL THEIR MONEY.
JUST TO GET A CHEESEBURGER
[inaudible]
AND IT WORKED AND IT WAS A
FISSION.
AND EVERYBODY HAD A GREAT TIME.
IT WAS ECONOMICAL AND THESE KIDS
DIDN'T HAVE TO BLOW ALL THEIR
BUDGETS.
THE HOST PARENTS HAT.
WE'RE ABLE TO DO IT.
IN THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE [inaudible]
WHEN?
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO TRAVEL
EXPRESSIONS TO THE COAST.
IT'S AN EXTREMELY HIGH COSTS.
IF I'M GONNA TAKE MY KIDS DOWN
TO SEA WORLD.
NOT NOT ONLY IS THE DRIVE A LONG
DRIVE FOR US.
BUT THEN THE HOTEL COSTS IS EVEN
MORE.
IT'S ME MORE TALK ABOUT TAKING
THE KIDS DOWN OF THE SAN DIEGO
ZOO DOWN TO ZERO DOWN ALL THESE
GREAT THINGS.
AND WE DON'T.
BECAUSE OF THE COST.
IT DOESN'T ADD UP.
IN THE ONLY OPTIONS REALLY
LAUGHED OR OR TO PLAN IT OUT TO
BUDGET IN NOW.
INDEED DO SOMETHING LIKE AN
INTERVIEW BECAUSE WE HAD TO HAVE
A LARGE FAMILY.
I I JUST DON'T IN AN ON A WHOLE
OTHER THING.
PICKING AND CHOOSING AND PIECE
MILLING WELL THIS IS GOOD FOR
THIS COUNTY BUT NOT THIS COUNTY.
WE'RE DOING POLICY FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE HERE.
AND AND IT DRIVES ME NUTS WHEN
WE TRY TO CARVE OUT.
SINGLE COUNTIES BECAUSE THE
COUNTIES HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THIS THEMSELVES IF THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO DO IT.
SO IF THOSE SUPERVISORS DON'T
WANT AIRBNB THEN THEY CAN STEP
UP AND DO THEIR OWN COUNTY
ORDINANCE. TO LOCK THE AIRBNB
EASE THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THESE THINGS.
SO IT IT IS.
I I DON'T THINK THE BILL'S PUT
TOGETHER RIGHT I THINK YOU'RE
TRYING -- TO OVERREACH AND I'M
NOT GOING TO SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU US SOME MEMBER EGGMAN.
YEAH JUST -- AND AND WE'VE WE'VE
ALREADY HAD THIS CONVERSATION
THAT -- I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO BUT AS SOMEBODY WHO
CAME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT I'VE
I JUST FEELS TO ME LIKE A REAL
OVER REACH I THINK PEOPLE HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DO THAT -- I'VE
I'VE TRAVELED AROUND IN THE WITH
THE NEW ORLEANS PLACES THEY HAVE
COME TOGETHER AND AND CREATED AN
ORDINANCE TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE OF OF HOUSING STOCK
VERSES.
PEOPLE AND IF YOU KNOW THERE'S
ONE THING HOPEFULLY NONE OF US
TRY TO DO IS BE A HYPOCRITE I'M
LOOKING.
AT MY OTHER IPAD BECAUSE THIS
THIS MORNING I BOOKED A PLACE TO
V. R. BO AND IN FORT BRAGG FOR
MY FAMILY TO BE ABLE TO GO OVER
THE HOLIDAYS SO MANY PEOPLE USE
IT PROVIDE YOU KNOW A LOT OF
HOTELS ARE EXPENSIVE.
THEM SO.
AS I SHARED WITH YOU I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO -- MAYBE THIS BILL COULD LAST
A BIT LONGER AND YOU CAN WORK TO
GET MORE WITH YOUR YOUR LOCALS.
AND SEE IF YOU CAN COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S WORKABLE AND
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBER.
I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW COMMENTS A
MINIMAL WILL ASK YOU TO CLOSE
FIRST OF ALL I HAVE TO HAND IT
TO FOR TAKING ON A REALLY
CONTROVERSY ALL.
AND REALLY DIFFICULT SUBJECT HI
YOU'RE TO BE COMMENDED THE I
KNOW THAT THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE
IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
AND I KNOW IT'S NOT EASY AND I
YOU KNOW I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
JUST THAT YOU WERE WILLING AS A
FRESHMAN TO JUMP IN AND AND TAKE
THIS ON YOU KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
YOU GET THE VOTES SO.
IF YOU KNOW GOOD FOR YOU -- AND
THERE IS A REAL PROBLEM WITH
AFFORDABILITY AND WITH LOSING --
OF LONG TERM YOU KNOW NORMAL
STABILIZE DEPARTMENTS IN YOUR
COMMUNITY -- AND YOU KNOW ALSO
FINDING THAT BALANCE WITH THE
COASTAL ACCESS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR PEOPLE -- TO
FIND ACCOMMODATIONS FOR SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS AND FOR
OVERNIGHT STAYS AND BALANCING
THAT IS VERY VERY DIFFICULT -- I
YOU KNOW I'M CONCERT I I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT SORT OF THE
FAVORITISM THAT IT'S SORT OF
SHOWING SOME PLATFORMS OVER
OTHERS AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE PLATFORMS THAT ARE
USED MORE.
MAY BE SEEN AS BEING MORE
DISRUPTIVE -- BUT KIND OF A
FOCUSING ON THE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS BUT LEAVING
CRAIG'S LIST LEAVING IT UP TO
PEOPLE TO RUN THEIR OWN WEBSITES --
IS A BIT OF A CONCERN FOR ME
GIVEN THAT CRISIS HAS NO
PROTECTIONS THAT OFFER THE USERS
WERE AS THE OTHER PLATFORMS DO
HAVE.
PROTECTIONS THEY ALSO DO WORK
BETTER WITH THE CITIES IN TERMS
OF COLLECTING TO TEAMWORK
CRAIG'S.
AND OTHER SITES DON'T DO THAT AT
ALL SO YOU KNOW TO ME THAT'S
THAT'S A BIT OF AN ISSUE I ALSO
THOUGHT THAT YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
COASTAL COMMISSION LIMITED
AUTHORITY. TO PROMOTE AFFORDABLE
VISITOR ACCOMMODATIONS AGAINST
PRESERVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WAS MAYBE SEVEN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION ITSELF COULD JUST BE
ASSIGNED TO TO TRY TO FIND A WAY
OF FINDING THAT BALANCE RATHER
RATHER THAN DOING THIS BILL.
HOWEVER WHAT I APPRECIATE IS
THAT YOU'RE DOING THIS AS A
PILOT IN A SMALL AREA WITH THE
STUDY AT THE END SO THAT WE CAN.
EVALUATE THIS SO THAT AS WE LOOK
AT OTHER AREAS THAT IN HIGH
DEMAND WHETHER IT'S THIS YEAR IS
OR TAHOE OR OTHER COASTAL AREAS
OR AT LEAST WILL BE DATA AND
KIND OF AN EXPERIMENT ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THIS.
WORKS AT ALL IT IS ABLE TO FIND
THAT BALANCE SO I I CAN SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY -- BUT AGAIN I
KNOW IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
IT'S A TOUGH SUBJECT AND WITH
THAT I WOULD INVITE YOU TO MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I AS I'VE ALWAYS DONE I
AM WELCOME I YOU KNOW I'M ALWAYS
WILLING TO WORK.
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND CONTINUE
TO KEEP OPEN DIALOGUES -- AND IT
REALLY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IT'S
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY -- YOU KNOW I I THINK AS
YOU KNOW EVERY CITY HAS THE
RIGHT TO REGULATE OR BAN ON
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS AS
THESE SEE FIT UNLESS YOU'RE IN
THE COASTAL ZONE.
AND SO THIS IS REALLY TRYING TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE OF ALL YOU
KNOW PRESERVING PROPERTY RIGHTS
PRESERVING LOCAL CONTROL -- BUT
PRESERVING BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION'S AUTHORITY OVER
COASTAL ACCESS BUT GETTING AT
THE TOP OF THE REMOVAL OF
HOUSING FOR MY HOUSING MARKET.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT CAN WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL -- I'M SORRY WE
DON'T HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
THE MOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ITEM FIVE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE BY BOERNER HORVATH THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
I'VE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING LIMóN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE I THREE TWO THREE TWO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH BEFORE
WE TAKE OUR LAST BILL I DO HAVE
A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES A PROPOSED TO
BE CONSENT TODAY -- ITEM ONE A.
B. THREE FIFTY THREE MURATSUCHI
AND ITEM TO AB SEVEN NINETY
THREE TING.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR COULD WE
PLEASE SEVERAL CALLS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY MELENDEZ WROTE
TWO G.. TWO G. AYE STONE
[inaudible]
PHONE I SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
IN THE FOLLOWINGMEASURES HAVE
BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S HEARING
ITEM THREE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
AND ITEM SIX AJ ARE.
SEVEN WITHOUT I'M GOING TO
PASSED THE GAVEL TO MISTER FLORA
AND PRESENT.
AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN MOVE THE BILL
[inaudible]
IF YOU
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRPERSON AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ASSESSES
ASSIST THE COMMUNITY PLAN UPDATE
PROCESS TO PROVIDE CLARITY TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RESIDENTS AND
DEVELOPERS AND HOW TO IMPLEMENT
AN UPDATE A COMMUNITY PLAN.
SHOULD ITS ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENT BE CHALLENGED IN COURT
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR WITH THIS
BILL SEEKS TO CO TO FIND TO
CLARIFY IS THAT ONCE A COMMUNITY
PLAN HAS BEEN ADOPTED.
AND PROJECTS OR TEAM THEIR
APPLICATION TO REDEEM COMPLETE
IF THE COMMUNITY PLAN SHOULD
SUBSEQUENTLY BE CHALLENGED IN
THE STATION BY THE COURT.
THOSE PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED AND DEEMED COMPLETE
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO CONTINUE THE
PROCESS OR ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN
APPROVED COULD CONTINUE WE WANT
TO JUST CLARIFY THAT'S THAT
THOSE PROJECTS ARE NOT PENALIZED.
AS THE LAWSUIT GOES FORWARD ONCE
THE JUDGE ISSUES A STAY AND SAYS
THE COMMUNITY PLAN HAS TO BE PUT
ON HOLD THE CITY COULDN'T ISSUE
ANY.
NEW OR BEGIN PROCESSING ANY NEW
APPLICATIONS SO THAT'S WHAT WE
WANTED TO CLARIFY YOU KNOW IN
SOME JURISDICTIONS IN A LOT OF
OUR LARGER CITIES AND EVEN IN
OUR MEDIUM CITY CITIES LIKE
GLENDALE.
THE COULD BE OUR COMMUNITY PLANS
ARE DONE NEIGHBORHOOD BY
NEIGHBORHOOD -- GLENDALE WHERE I
LIVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME A
COUPLE YEARS DOING A SOUTH
GLENDALE COMMUNITY PLAN AND THEN
ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS LATER THE
PLAN WAS CHALLENGED IN COURT
WE'RE SIMPLY SAYING THAT A FOR
PROFIT IF.
AN APPLICATION IS PROCESS UNDER
THAT NEW PLAN THAT THE CITY%
SPENT YEARS DOING.
AND THE PEOPLE GOT THEIR
ENTITLEMENTS OR HAD A COMPLETE
APPLICATION THAT THAT OVERALL
CHALLENGE SHOULDN'T AFFECTED
THEIR RIGHT TO GO FORWARD EVEN
THOUGH NO NEW.
PROJECTS COULD BE PROCESSED --
AND THEN INSTANCE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THEIR LAND USE ELEMENT
IS COMPRISED OF THIRTY FIVE
SEPARATE COMMUNITY PLANS THAT
ALL CONTAIN GUIDING GOALS AND
PRINCIPLES FOR HOW EACH PLANET
SHOULD GROW -- WITHOUT I HAVE A
WITNESS TODAY.
SILVA SOLICITAR ON BEHALF OF
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB -- FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN CHERRY MEMBER SYLVIA'S
ALICIA ON BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI I
THINK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND
TO TO THE COMMITTEE CONSULTA AND
TO THE CHAIR -- THE CITY AND THE
MAYOR HAVE PRIORITIZED THE
UPDATING OF OUR COMMUNITY PLANS
BY -- TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WE'VE A
COMMITTED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND HAVE INCREASED OUR COMMUNITY
PLANNING STAFF TO DO THAT TO DO
JUST THIS WE'RE WORKING TO ALIGN
OUR LAND USE POLICIES WITH STATE
AND LOCAL GOALS THAT SUPPORT
BOTH INCREASED HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS -- AS THE CHAIR
STATED WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF UPDATING SIXTEEN
PLANS HAVE TO HAVE THEM ALL
UPDATED BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WE'VE EXPERIENCED UNCERTAINTY IN
THE PAST WITH RESPECT
IMPLEMENTATION OF ADOPTED LAND
USE PLANS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO A
SECRET CHALLENGE.
AND THIS BILL WOULD CLARIFY HOW
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN PROCEED
WITH IMPLEMENTING NEW PLANS
DURING SUCH A CHALLENGE AND
THESE COMMUNITY PLANS ARE VERY
DEFINED AND LIMITED.
IN THE LEGISLATION -- SO THIS
BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY TO THOSE
CITIES WITH THOSE VERY SPECIFIC
TYPES OF COMMUNITY PLANS SO
AGAIN A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
REMOVES AMBIGUITY HELPING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PROPERTY OWNERS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE PLANS CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE EVENT OF A
CHALLENGE.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NEARLY COVERAGE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS WE APPRECIATE THE
CLEAR PATH THAT THIS BILL
CREATES AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY OPPOSITION.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEE AN NINE ABOUT I'M SURE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I HAVE A CONSECUTIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOR A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
BY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY MELENDEZ WROTE
TO TREAT.
BREAST TO GI STONE [inaudible]
STONE NO.
THANK YOU.
FOR SEVEN ONE THANK YOU HAVE
BILLS -- SEVEN ONE WE NEED TO
LOOK THE CALLS.
WE NEED TO LIVE THE COST -- IF
WE CAN GO TO THE FIRST ITEM
PLEASE.
YEAH WELL IF THE COFFERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
MOTION TO PASS WITH CONCERT
RECOMMENDATION CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHOW I LIVE ALONE [inaudible]
LIMóN [inaudible]
LIMON I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
MELENDEZ AYE [inaudible] TEN
ZERO I AM.
ONE I DON'T FOR A BI FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN MEMBER FRIEDMAN TO PASS
A VOTE THE SEVEN TO ONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MULLIN AYE.
STONE -- I'M SORRY NOT STONE.
STONE.
YEAH YOU ARE NOW.
YOU'RE NOT YEAH [inaudible]
EIGHT ONE WHAT.
OKAY NEXT ITEM.
ITEM FIVE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE BY BURNER WHOLE RAFT TO PASS
AS AMENDED PROVO IS THREE TO TWO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHILD.
CHAU AYE.
LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S NO [inaudible] FIVE
THREE AND SIX THE VOTE IS.
FIVE TO THREE INTO THIS. ONE
OKAY FROM.
OKAY I'LL GO SEE IF I CAN
[inaudible]
WHATEVER.
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR FIVE MINUTES.
THE REST OF YOU CAN [inaudible]
ONE FIVE FOR YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THE RIGHT NUMBER OKAY PERFECT
YEAH THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
AND AND SO [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
OKAY
.
READ ALL OF THE CALL -- FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO VOTE WE'LL
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE COAT
CURRENT VOTE THIS TENDED ZERO
WITH THE TERM VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBER MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I ELEVEN ZERO NEXT.
ITEM FOR A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
FRIEDMAN MOTIONS TO PASS -- VOTE
EIGHT TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBER MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NINE ONE ITEM FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE CORNER ****
BATH.
DO PASS AS AMENDED CURRENT VOTE
FIVE TO THREE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBER MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I SIX THREE SIX TO THREE
THAT THOSE OUT.
WITH THAT WE ARE TURN